Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number
and that number is 2192. David P I
mentioned Jewish Christmas, which is of
course, you get Chinese or Indian food
or really any place that's open, right?
It just tends to be Asian restaurants.
And there is a caller who is not
thrilled with the Indian food
component of it. Take a listen to this.
Speaker 3: David is down from Jersey and
watching the show today. And you're saying that
the Jewish Christmas is Chinese or Indian food,
correct? I do not understand the meaning of the
season, the Christmas spirit. How could you? It's
just like Jesus died for our sins, David. And this
is the day we celebrate his birth. Not by Indians
who did the most ridiculous thing I've ever heard.
Everyone knows it's Chinese food and the movie.
Days of Chinese food and a movie. Never Indians.
I don't know. You can do Indian food the rest of
the year, but this day Jesus died so we can have
the day off for our movie and Chinese food. Okay.
And specifically has to be like maybe Avatar two.
Speaker 1: Anyway, we're now getting a little bit
too detailed, so this is a joke. I don't think
that guy's really mad that I ate Indian food
on Christmas. But yes, there is a long tradition
there that in fact, a lot of interesting sort of
sort of like articles and research into this. How
did it end up that Jewish folks get Asian food on
Christmas? And of course, the answer is relatively
simple. Christmas is really boring if you're
Jewish. I remember from when I was a kid, now it's
less boring because no matter what day it is, I'm
just chasing around a baby. But that's a different
story. But historically, it's a very boring day
and you order from the restaurants that are
open. And typically those are Asian restaurants
of different kinds. I believe Indian food is
just as acceptable as Chinese food on Christmas.
If you disagree with me, you can let me know.
We have a fantastic bonus show for you today.
Speaker 3: Oh, the bonus show where you
want to make money and everybody else
that makes money to fund themselves is back.
Speaker 1: Well, we'll see if any money is
made today. On today's bonus show, we are going to
talk about the Supreme Court saying the Trump era
border restrictions under Title 42 will remain
in effect while legal challenges play out. Very
controversial, very hypocritical. Much of what's
gone on with Title 42, we will talk about it. A
bill forcing the feds to fix prison cameras has
been signed into law. Prison cameras are actually
a big topic. And I recently actually wrote a
book about prisons. And we're going to talk
about the prison cameras. There's actually quite
a connection to police body cameras as well there,
which we will discuss. And then lastly, it
has been revealed that Donald Trump didn't
realize that the White House schedule was a
public document until there were only weeks
left of his presidency. He then realized, wait a
second, what I'm doing daily gets published. And
at that point he asked for a much more generic
version to be published. And that's when you
might remember in the last few weeks of Trump's
presidency, his schedule started to say things
like The president will have many meetings with
various people and work for the American people.
And we wondered, That's really weird. Why are they
doing that? It's clearly that Trump isn't working.
He only learned then. That the president's
official schedule is a public document which
is just mind blowing. All of those stories and
more today on the bonus show when producer Pat
joins me. Remember, get the free whitepaper
on how to argue politics with people without
burning the bridge of the relationship with
them. There's a free guide. It's free. It's
really free. I'm not selling you anything. You
can find it at David Pakman dot com slash guide.
David Pakman dot com slash guide. It's free. We'll
see you on the bonus show and back here tomorrow.